in just 20 months on the job joe biden
has set a number of statistical records
he's brought us the highest gas prices
ever recorded the highest inflation in
40 years the lowest quarterly approval
rating for any modern president and now
just yesterday joe biden hit a new
numerical record
two
million apprehensions of illegal
immigrants across our southern border in
just one year
remember those are just the
apprehensions there are many hundreds of
thousands of additional immigrants that
were not apprehended
as well as another million immigrants
let into the country legally meaning
that this year joe biden has brought
into the country
three new immigrants for every four
americans who turned 18.
if you've had the sneaking suspicion
lately that the nation is rapidly
changing that is probably because the
nation at its most basic level that is
the people who constitute it
are rapidly changing through an
intentional policy of mass migration the
largest movement of human beings in
recorded history now what's strange
about this scenario is that according to
a harvard harris survey just about four
years ago the majority of americans want
to drastically reduce
all immigration both legal and illegal
the last republican president was
elected in large part on the promise
that he would build a gigantic wall and
drastically reduce immigration and he
actually tried to do that for years for
years to fulfill that campaign promise
but it just didn't happen
he was stopped by the courts
by the bureaucracy
by crooked corporations that have a lot
of political influence and that rely on
cheap labor
all of which undermined the clearly
articulated will
and rights of the american people and
then this is where it gets really crazy
when a republican governor in florida
decided to charter a plane and fly just
a few dozen of those millions and
millions of illegal aliens up to a
wealthy liberal beach town
he found himself the subject of both a
criminal investigation
and a lawsuit by the illegal aliens who
in an even remotely sensible nation
would have been deported the very moment
that they hopped the border
but we don't live in a sane sensible
nation anymore
it's hard to say that we even live in a
nation anymore
certainly not a nation defined by
self-government
more and more it seems as though we live
in a borderless liberal empire where our
leaders improvise the rules as they go
along and always to the same purpose no
matter how the game is played no matter
what the numbers show no matter what the
other players want the liberals always
have to win i'm michael knowles this is
the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from rba who says
okay everybody hit the showers now has a
different meaning for one team ah this i
suppose in that reaction to the umass
football team presenting itself as super
duper rainbow flags everywhere lgbt
uh while playing the christian
conservative school liberty university
that's true does sure gives a different
meaning to some of that locker room talk
when you want to protect yourself you've
obviously got to check out
ring right now head on over to ring.com
knowles the start
of fall is always so busy especially for
me it's speech season now i'm hitting
the road all the time but i can rest
easy why because of ring
alarm now i know what you're thinking
ring the video doorbell company they've
got an alarm they do ring alarm is an
award-winning home security system with
available professional monitoring when
you subscribe best of all you can easily
install it yourself and ring did not
stop there they changed the home
security game with ring alarm pro that
is why i love ring i strongly recommend
that you become a pro like me gopro with
ring alarm pro ring alarm pro is a whole
home security system with available
professional monitoring when you
subscribe to ring protect pro ring alarm
pro combines a security system
with a fast eero wi-fi 6 router
for home security and network security
in one device your physical home your
digital home you get it all
if anything happens professional
monitoring calls and can request
emergency services
this fall
whether you are in your home whether
you're at the office whether you're
across the country make sure that you
are protected okay head on over to ring
get ring alarm pro
ring.com knowles that is ring.com
knowles
the illegal aliens that got the free
private jet
vacation to martha's vineyard one of the
nicest
vacation resorts on planet earth a place
that most of us will never have the
opportunity to go now they are they the
illegal the people who are in this
country illegally
are suing the governor of florida
for
sending them there after they after they
signed a waiver saying that they were
happy to go there
this is
thanks to a group called lawyers for
civil rights it's a leftist group
and they claimed that florida officials
quote designed and executed a
premeditated fraudulent and illegal
scheme centered on exploiting this
vulnerability
for the sole purpose of advancing their
own personal financial and political
interests i'm going to take a pause
right there
personal interests and political
interests are sort of
opposite categories by personal means
it's just private political means it's
public now i guess i have a personal
interest in my politics being good
insane and normal so in that sense they
have it but what did the uh what what
did the florida election of the florida
governing officials rather you know the
governor of florida and the legislature
and the whole staff
what do they get out of this
well they're forcing the liberals to
deal with the consequences of their own
immigration policies that's it that's
all they're getting out of it in the
hopes that the liberals will then see
what's going on feel the political
pressure and then stop importing
millions and millions of illegals every
single year into border states then the
lawyers claimed that the illegal
immigrants were enticed to get on the
private jet to martha's vineyard with
perks such as 10 mcdonald's gift
certificates you know for me if you
offered me a free trip to martha's
vineyard on a private jet i wouldn't
even need the 10 mcdonald's gift
certificate
they're bringing this lawsuit because
ron desantis did to a very small degree
what joe biden in the federal government
has been doing at a very large scale
that is
taking illegals who make it into america
and then just flying them all around the
country the liberals are already doing
this exact thing they're just doing it
to places that are not nearly as nice as
martha's vineyard
so we can say well it's hypocrisy
well imagine if the shoe were on the
other foot gosh what if the roles were
reversed right they know it's hypocrisy
they don't care this is not about rules
this is not about the law of course the
most
the most obvious takeaway from this is
why are these immigrants able to sue the
governor at all they shouldn't be here
the minute that they raise their hands
and say hey i'm here illegally ice
should descend and ship them out of this
country because they are flagrantly
flamboyantly breaking the nation's most
basic laws
but that doesn't happen
because the rules that we ostensibly
live under are not the real rules that
govern our society
just like the constitution capital c
that nice piece of parchment that we
ostensibly live under is not the real
lowercase c constitution that governs
our society what really governs our
society are the real power structures
that exist and in the real power
structures that exist the democrats get
to import millions of illegals every
year and fly them all around the country
and send them all to the red states to
try to gain a permanent electoral
advantage and the minute the republicans
push back at all in the least do even
one one thousandth of what of exactly
what the democrats are doing that's a
national case you're going to find
yourself under criminal investigation
you're going to find yourself the
subject of many lawsuits
so what's desantis doing now that he's
getting this
massive amount of threats coming at him
from the left
he's doubling down there was where is it
there was a terrific article yesterday
came out
governor desantis
might send illegal aliens to rehoboth
beach delaware now this was something
that
ted cruz suggested a year ago he said
you've got to send these illegal
immigrants not just to dc in new york
you got to send them to martha's
vineyard and nantucket not just martha's
vineyard in nantucket you got to send it
to rehoboth beach delaware you got to
send it to where joe biden
stays
and
that was the headline yesterday
and then this is the key here
it didn't happen
governor desantis threatened to send
migrants to biden's delaware home it was
a no-show
state officials mobilized community
groups stood by to help reporters and
camera crews staked out airports but the
plane and the migrants
never showed
this confusing drama was the latest
chapter in an ongoing spat between biden
and governor desantis
amid his threat to send migrants to
sanctuary jurisdictions around the
country this was this was really smart
and it's i tell you this whole episode
is giving me more and more respect for
desantis every day
because desantis knows you can't be
predictable here
the first the first move was great
sends them to martha's vineyard proves
that the libs aren't really hoping for
to host sanctuary cities don't really
like the immigrants act actually compare
the immigrants to trash end up deporting
the immigrants and sending them to a
military camp for that within 44 hours
of their arrival
right that was hilarious
and then if he had just sent them again
the democrats would have been better
prepared so what he does is he threatens
to send them again he doesn't actually
send them the state officials mobilize
they're ready we're going to activate
all of the authorities this is an
emergency and then it doesn't happen and
they look very very foolish because
desantis can now look at them and say
hey
why were you all so worried why were you
all mobilizing why were you
on the verge of calling in the national
guard because i was going to send a
plane of those people in that you say
it's so wonderful to invite into our
country that you say you want to give
sanctuary to but you don't actually do
that then what's he do in between those
two stunts he hits him with a great
immigration ad where you've got a woman
telling that this true tragic story of
her son getting killed by an illegal
immigrant had the democrats not invited
the illegal immigrants into the country
her son would still be alive this was
obviously planned out it's not just
little trolls and tactics it's part of a
longer-term strategy
and it's a strategy that the dems can't
predict this is the key this this was
one of if not the greatest strength of
donald trump was his unpredictability
it's why his foreign policy was the
greatest foreign policy in my lifetime
is because
all those bad guys around the world
actually thought twice
kim jong-un when he sees this tweet from
this crazy guy donald trump that says
i've got a big nuclear button and my
button actually works don't tempt me bro
he's probably thinking look 95 chance
trump doesn't do anything but five
percent who the hell knows trump runs as
a dove candidate he runs against all of
the wars and then one day he decides to
take out the top iranian general and you
just don't know you know the you think
this guy is going to zig and then he
zags and desantis who has obviously
learned a ton of tricks from donald
trump this is one of the things he's
learned as well it's something
conservatives need to be aware of
constantly you've got to be
unpredictable do not
let the libs lure you into a steady
predictable pattern of behavior
keep up keep up the pressure keep up the
political leverage but don't let them
know where you're going
the
this stuff is really really popular
okay
this stuff is a big political winner
it's not a big political winner in the
news media it's not a big political
winner among the establishment but the
american people love this stuff i quoted
that harvard harris poll democrats never
want to talk about this poll it was in
2018 and the way it phrased the question
it didn't ask do you want to reduce
immigration because when polls ask that
question then it's a much more of a
mixed bag
all the poll asked was what do you think
is a good level
of immigration
including legal immigration and most
people said for legal immigration
about 500 000 people per year
or less
and then
no illegal immigration
five hundred thousand people we take in
three million people a year
so when you actually get down to the
numbers the vast majority of americans
want to drastically reduce all
immigration
okay because you couldn't even get down
to that number if you only got rid of
all illegal immigration you'd have to
reduce legal immigration too the
policies are popular you see this with
pro pro choice and pro-life when you ask
questions about abortion and you use the
phrases pro-choice and pro-life
it's kind of a mixed bag when you get
into the nitty-gritty of when when
people think that you ought to be able
to kill a baby
when you get into the nitty-gritty of
what abortion actually looks like the
country is overwhelmingly pro-life
this stuff is very very popular
when you just present it to people
we win
if you ask someone hey do you think that
we should tolerate transgenderism and
gender affirming care i promise you the
polls are going to be a big mixed bag
maybe the majority of americans are even
for it when you show them what it
actually means that gender affirming
care means hacking off people's forearms
and calves and constructing a fake
frankenstein-esque looking phallus or
some kinds of fake genitals that you sew
on chopping little girl's breasts off
hideous dr frankenstein stuff
those numbers are going to plummet into
nothing okay it's for the libs they've
got to use all these euphemisms and
euphemisms or soft words that are
designed to
soften harsh truths and then the way the
libs use them is actually to invert the
truth so instead of referring to an
illegal alien which is which is a very
precise technical term means a foreign
national
they use this term undocumented american
well whatever you think of illegal
aliens they sure ain't american okay
it's ju that's not that's not softening
a harsh truth that's actually inverting
reality that's what the libs have to do
and and then they can win the
conservatives all we have to do is show
people the reality the reality of
immigration the reality of
transgenderism the reality of abortion
the reality of these political
circumstances then we win people are
seeing the reality right now because the
political realities are so in our face
gas is at
not all-time highs it's declined a
little bit over the summer but gas
prices are very very high food prices
are very very high inflation year over
year is eight and a half percent okay
people's dollars are not going nearly as
far you can just see it with your own
eyes
and when people see that reality the gop
does very well right now according to
the latest ajc poll the gop is leading
in all georgia races don't forget
georgia in that after the crazy 2020
election
georgia and those runoffs is
what through the senate to the democrats
well right now the gop is absolutely
killing it even herschel walker versus
rafael warnock
herschel the republican warnock the
democrat and warnock had been doing very
very well in the race now it's 4644
herschel brian kemp is running way ahead
of stacey abrams 50-42 i'm sure stacey
abrams still she could get beaten 90-10
she still wouldn't concede the race
she's going to be the governor in her
own mind you're seeing
gop state senator bert jones leading
charlie bailey 43 to 33 gop attorney
general chris carr absolutely destroying
democrat state senator jen jordan
45 to 35 destroying her with facts and
logic and votes the list goes on and on
and on if the liberals want to win this
race they're going to have to cheat
okay and they are probably going to
cheat they're going to try to cheat
they're going to try to push widespread
mail-in ballots
they're going to try to extend election
day to a lecture they've already done
that they're going to try to extend
election day very very far and why
they're going to try to suppress gop
poll watchers this is regular stuff this
isn't crazy conspiracy theory stuff
democrats tried to do this virtually
every election and now it's a lot easier
because of the way they changed the
rules in 2020. now speaking of cheating
i've got to change gears a little bit
here
i mentioned yesterday that the singer
from maroon 5 is being accused of
cheating on his wife and mother of his
three children with some instagram
chick
and i
i don't really care about the story
about any of these people in the story
in particular but i do care about the
story because it is truly a warning for
everybody okay the the update on on
maroon 5k
is this chick posted
uh
dms that the maroon 5 singer had sent
her hitting on her obviously trying to
initiate some sort of affair she then
claims they had a year-long affair and
that he kept messaging her even after
that he's now saying okay i sent her the
messages because that part's undeniable
but he's saying all right we never had
the affair though he said i used poor
judgment in speaking with anyone other
than my wife in any kind of flirtatious
manner i did not have an affair
nevertheless i crossed the line during a
regrettable period of my life in certain
instances it became inappropriate i've
addressed that and taken proactive steps
to remedy this with my family my wife
and my family it's all i care about in
this world to be this and i even stupid
enough to risk the only thing that truly
matters to me was the greatest mistake i
could ever make i will never make it
again i take full responsibility we will
get through it and we will get through
it together okay
i'm not even mentioning the story i'm
not mentioning it to beat up on the girl
the girl's pretending to be a victim
here she's not really a victim she
willingly and knowingly had an affair
with a married man with kids she should
atone for her sins
kind of remain quiet and not make a big
spectacle out of herself but i'm not
mentioning the story to beat up on her
i'm not even mentioning the story to
beat up on him as drew clavin says every
man has two drinks and a wink away from
burning down his life okay so yes there
but for the grace of god go all of us
the reason i mention this story
is because
of
a
moral
and uh
it's a sort of moral trick
okay but it's really helpful for people
who write into this show a lot we had
this long conversation last night on
backstage about porn and then it kind of
became a conversation about all sorts of
sins and vices and on the mailbag of
this show i don't know a fifth a quarter
maybe a third of the messages i get are
from young men who are hooked on porn
and they say it's a really big problem
in their lives
the trick here is avoiding the near
occasion of sin
okay and
it sounds like really moral religious
language and it is but it's
even if you if you're an atheist even if
you don't take religion that seriously
this is just a really practical tool for
your own life
did this guy have an affair
or not it certainly seems like he did
but regardless
he didn't start screwing up when he had
the affair
he didn't even start screwing up when he
messaged the hot instagram girl
he started screwing up
when he went on instagram
and he knew that he would find this kind
of content
if you want two of what people write in
they said that this was the question on
the backstage show last night how how
can my husband stop looking at porn
he's he he's not going to stop it at the
at the point of looking at the porn he's
going to stop it a few steps back he's
going to maybe put some safeguards on
his computer he's going to maybe use his
computer or his phone or his ipad or
whatever in a different way he's going
to get hobbies he's going to spend his
time differently
he's got to avoid at the near occasion
of sin mike pence got in big trouble for
this five or six years ago when he said
that he doesn't have private dinners
with women
if he's having a dinner with a woman his
wife has to be present and the libs
called him sexist and awful and terrible
for this then five seconds later the me
too scandal breaks out
and and
they wouldn't give mike pence any credit
even though what mike pence is saying is
i love my wife i don't want to put women
in a bad position and i don't want to
put me in a near occasion of sin so i'm
just not going to do that
they get angry at mike pence for not
cheating on his wife basically but what
mike pence did is very very smart
because he's saying look i don't think
i'd cheat on my wife certainly don't
want to cheat on my wife but i'm a man i
got red blood i don't want to put myself
in a situation where that is going to be
tempting or a risk or even it could have
the whiff of scandal or it could even
look improper i'm just not going to do
that at all this is an important lesson
for everybody don't
don't put yourself in the situation
where the temptation is going to be so
great and overwhelm you that that's a
sin in and of itself okay be smart about
this stuff or else you're going to look
like a total schmuck and you're going to
burn down your life and you're going to
lose the things the only things that
really matter to you in life and you're
gonna have no one but yourself to blame
for it okay speaking of shameful sex
stuff
really really big story just came out of
daily wire our pal matt walsh has been
on this jihad against the transgender
movement
ever since his movie came out what is a
woman and he's been
digging up and the research team here at
daily wire have been digging up videos
from these transgender clinics
specifically the pediatric transgender
clinics you remember what happened at
the boston children's hospital the
boston children's hospital got caught by
libs of tick tock
saying that they performed these crazy
gender surgeries
on on children on people who are
16 years old or younger
13 years old
okay and this this is a big scandal
people were rightly very upset about
this well turns out this is happening in
our own backyard vanderbilt hospital
here in nashville tennessee has a
pediatric gender clinic
and matt and the research team here at
daily wire have dug up some videos of
them explaining exactly how this
transgender clinic started now when you
want to talk to me about this and so
many other things you've got
to write in to the voice mail bag
puretalk sponsors the voicemail bag
how do you do it
you head on over to the michael knowles
show page at the daily wire you click on
watch you click on the michael knowles
show then you click submit a mailbag
question now and you can type out your
question if you want or on your phone or
on your computer you can record just a
little
voice recording
less than one minute please so that we
can feature it on the show and then you
just attach it as a file to the email
send it in and we will hear your
mellifluous and dulcet voice on friday
the vanderbilt pediatric transgender
clinic
started four years ago
sort of surreptitiously they didn't want
to make too many waves they just wanted
to make a bunch of money preying on
sexually confused kids with very
confused and sometimes predatory parents
and put these kids on cross-sex hormones
mutilate their bodies and make them
patients for life the the
the key to this expose is the reason
that one of the leaders of the pediatric
transgender clinic gave
for why they started it up
insurance cover carriers are mandated to
cover medical expenses for trans folks
um
some of our umc financial folks in 20 in
august of 20th or october of 2016
started a couple years ago put down some
costs of how much money we think each
patient would bring in and this is only
including top surgery this isn't
including any bottom surgery
and um it's a lot of money these
surgeries make a lot of money
so female to male and chest
reconstruction can bring in forty
thousand dollars a patient just on
routine hormone treatment who i've only
seen a few times a year
can bring in several thousand dollars
that requires a lot of visits and labs
it actually makes money for the hospital
um and then the female to male bottom
surgeries these are huge money makers
again i think this has to be an
underestimate that they're voting around
twenty thousand dollars for a
phalloplasty there's been different
things that i've read that said it could
be up to a hundred thousand dollars um
dr lineker who's our surgeon says that
there's entire clinics where the entire
clinic is supported just by their
phalloplasties and that is like a
fraction of the surgeries that they're
doing
these are huge money makers and of
course they are some of us have been
pointing this out for years now
that when you get anybody to go down the
transgender rabbit hole you create a
very very lucrative patient for life
because these people have open wounds
all sorts of horrible mutilations
they've got to take all sorts of drugs
and it's very very expensive and big
pharma and the health establishment make
a lot of money on that
so do you know how you can make even
more money than getting some poor
depressed mentally ill 25 year old to
chop off his genitals and take a bunch
of expensive drugs if you get kids to do
it because then you've got a patient for
10 years longer or more
you've got that patient for life and as
their health deteriorates and there are
more complications from this sort of
mutilation they're going to need more
and more expensive drugs and
interventions
and that's not just some crazy
conspiracy theory
that's what one of the heads of the
pediatric gender clinic just said
when she was explaining why they
established the clinic
all of which means by the way
that when while we're talking about
giving out these these really
difficult drugs
to kids i've got a really difficult hard
to swallow pill for conservatives what
this means is that the transgender mania
including and especially transiting the
kids is not just a product of leftism
it's not just a product of cultural
marxism it is a product of those things
but it is just as much a product of
capitalism and individualism these
people are just out to make a buck and
the capitalist ideology don't forget
capitalism although a lot of
conservatives identify as capitalists
and tout capitalism capitalism is a word
that was popularized by karl marx okay
capitalism is a godless modern ideology
that worships mammon that does one one
of the
key things in the bible that the bible
says do not do worship mammon that's
what it does and what you get out of
this is the kind of 1980s
caricature american psycho gordon gecko
greed is good kind of thing this idea
that the economy is morally neutral that
we've just got to pursue profit
ruthlessly this ein rand sociopathy
okay
this is what that leads to
this leads to treating human beings not
as
as your brothers and and fellow uh
creatures made in the image and likeness
of god but is treating them
as just just something to be used for
your own benefit so you can make a buck
even if it means chopping off a kid's
genitals well hey that's going to be a
really great way to make a lot of money
so whatever as long as they consent to
it that's fine and and in the modern era
because we've thrown morality out the
window and all we care about is making
money the only the only moral criterion
that we even discuss at all is consent
well as long as two people consent to it
that's absolutely fine now of course in
the case of children they cannot consent
so the the liberals are trying to
convince everyone that children can give
consent that's one of the explicit
arguments they're making but in this
case they can say well the parents
consent to it and it's the parent's job
to raise the kids so as long as we get
the parents to consent it's totally fine
but it's not totally fine
and in a world in which moral criteria
don't really matter or they're
unintelligible and we can't have those
kinds of conversations about what is
good and true and beautiful and virtuous
then all that matters is individual
choice and so you'll you'll very often
hear people say well look
if an individual wants to mutilate his
body well that's none of my business who
cares
well i think it is my business for two
reasons one because i've got faculties
of reasons and i can separate truth from
false and right from wrong but two
because i live in a society and we have
self-government so actually the things
that we're allowed to do and not allowed
to do it's everybody's business in in
all societies in all political
communities but especially in
self-government because in america at
least
in the olden days at least according to
the constitution we're supposed to be
the people who make the laws so yes it
very much is our business
but we don't want to talk that way
anymore and it's especially people on
the right who don't want to talk that
way anymore we just talk about
individuals well it's your choice do
whatever you want
because we've thrown out this notion of
duty which is has always been essential
to the conservative worldview until
about
five minutes ago until really 20 30
years ago
when duty was replaced by rights and
my freedom and my individual choice
because of that we can no longer say no
a man who was born a man has a duty has
a responsibility to act like a man don
corleone johnny fontaine what can you do
you can act like a man what's the matter
with you and women have a responsibility
to act like women that our bodies that
the the
the given circumstances of
ourselves
actually dictate some of the things that
we ought to do we can't just do whatever
the hell we want we don't have a right
to do that at least
and if you accept that premise that
conservative premise then of course you
got to get rid of the crazy transgender
surgery it's harmful doctors take an
oath first to do no harm
okay it's it's harmful to the patients
it's harmful to society it's based on a
false anthropology just get rid of it
especially for kids but for everybody
okay or if you
if if the conservatives even the
conservatives throw these moral criteria
out the window then we're basically just
the libs
and it all just comes down to
choice
personal interest personal base desire
the only difference is conservatives
talk a little bit more about making
money but only a little bit more you
hear that lib i guarantee you that
doctor is a big lib and she's talking
about it too she goes these transgender
surgeries on kids they're going to make
us a lot of money
at that point if you throw out the duty
and the obligation the criteria and the
transcendent moral order and the virtue
then all the conservatives are is just
greedy liberals they're just especially
greedy liberals
right
people who say you know i'm fiscally
conservative but socially liberal all
that means is you're a greedy liberal
you don't even want to give your money
and taxes to the poor
you want all the terrible liberal stuff
and you're greedy
and you're extra greedy on top of it not
good not good folks we need a little bit
of introspection here
because we can whine and complain and
say oh the terrible left is doing this
yeah we let them do it how did we let
them do it
the people broadly
have common sense i think that's what
we're talking about earlier on
immigration on abortion on the
transgender issue the people have common
sense they know this stuff is wrong
okay i think they're with us
overwhelmingly
so then how did we let the libs win how
did we let how do we let it go so far
it's because of a failure
of conservatives it's because in many
ways we've accepted the libs premises
but people know this stuff is wrong you
remember the teacher i was talking about
yesterday that canadian male teacher
who's got some kind of bizarre sexual
fetish and who wears these giant size
triple z prosthetic breasts into the
classroom and he's a shop teacher which
seems especially dangerous but they're
these very gigantic
obscene
prosthetic breasts and he dresses up
like a woman and the guy obviously needs
serious counseling and he needs some
spiritual direction and he might need to
be committed to an insane asylum
unfortunately our society has gone
insane so the insane asylum is just the
country that's where we live and this is
true up in canada up in america's hat as
well peter bogosian
is really interesting academic he's he's
one of the guys along with james james
lindsay behind the
uh
so-called squared grievance studies hoax
that happened a few years ago where
these academics submitted completely
bogus nonsensical papers
on all sorts of critical theory and
grievance studies to academic journals
and they were accepted and it was very
very funny so peter pagosian he tweets
out
most people have strong moral impulses
about whether this individual this male
teacher with the fake giant prosthetic
breasts should be allowed to teach their
children in a public school but very few
can construct a good argument why or why
not it's more difficult than you think
try it
so i don't think it's difficult at all i
think it's very simple to construct an
argument as to why and the argument is
this the purpose of school is to educate
students
not to corrupt students
the purpose of education is to show
students and instruct them in
the good true and beautiful ways to
behave and ways to think and and to
introduce them to this kind of knowledge
in that way not to
corrupt them
right it's to develop their rational
wills not their lowest appetites right
and so this man who is so egregiously
deviant
obviously is not suited to educate he is
only suited to corrupt and scrub
people's brains and so he should not be
teaching i think it's a very simple
argument very obviously true
and i don't know maybe peter doesn't
want to make an argument like that but
but he might just be saying something
deeper too
i'm not sure he might just be saying
look we all know this is wrong even if
you can't construct an argument for it
can't we all just accept that it's wrong
isn't there a sort of wisdom to
repugnance as the bioethicist leon cass
might say and we can just know you just
you just look at it and i'm not saying
this is right 100 of the time but we
just know thanks to good prejudice
we just know that this pervert teacher
wearing the weird sexual fetish costume
to the classroom
is not right and we can say no to that
at least traditionally in
self-government we have been allowed to
say no to that whether we still can or
not i suppose remains to be seen
so you've stopped giving your money to
woke razor companies that hate you
you've bought jeremy's razors instead
good on you every dollar we take away
from the libs is one dollar saved from
misuse but that is a fringe benefit
compared to the jeremy's racers contest
for the car that we've just launched
here's how it works for every person you
refer whether they buy a jeremy's razors
kit or a daily wire annual membership
you both get points in the race to win
the god king's mclaren
now listen this isn't just
a masculine car
it actually spells out the word
masculine in exhaust fumes i would know
i was standing right behind it when
jeremy peeled out of the parking lot
yesterday if you refer enough people you
just might win it seriously
a
3.8 liter v8 powered sports car with
hundreds more horsepower than my honda
civic i know it's as shocking because my
honda civic i basically feel like vin
diesel in that thing but the mclaren
even more powerful now i know
ben believes that he has the best and
smartest audience out there but if one
of you were to win i would be able to
prove him wrong once and we all know it
but i'd be able to prove it once and for
all so it would not only be a win for
you but a big win for me too to sign up
and start competing go to jeremy's
razors.com play the race for the car
ends on november 1st so get in the
competition today see terms and
conditions for complete details at
jeremy's razors.com referral terms the
program is open only to legal u.s
residents residing in the us and d.c
excluding residents of colorado
connecticut maryland puerto rico and u.s
territories and possessions 18 and older
remember friends don't let friends shave
with woke razors
the the crazy teacher in canada with the
gigantic prosthetic breasts and
the the school defends the teacher even
though the parents and the students are
rightly complaining about it
it
raises this point that we haven't seemed
to
appreciate recently which is
in order to have
education you need to agree on the
purpose what's the purpose of education
are you going to learn the liberal arts
are you going to learn the technical
arts are you going to learn
how to be a sadomasochist are you going
to learn how to become a sort of pervert
are you going to learn
communism are you going to learn
something
education has to have an end it has to
have a t loss it has to you you have to
be
aiming at something together
the same is true of a political
community
all political communities
cities states nations
are
people living together in community with
a common purpose
what are we after what are we all about
what what are we all doing together
it is not enough just to say well we're
just here
i'm just here to protect my rights
right in a way that's a sort of purpose
too
or we're going to spread democracy
abroad i don't know that's necessarily
the smartest purpose hasn't worked out
very well historically but that would be
one purpose
or we're going to build up american
industry and and be a shining city on a
hill for others to see a beacon of hope
to the world
that's one there but we have to have we
have to agree on what we're doing and
increasingly we can't do that because
the libs have their own perverted moral
view that tears down all that is
traditionally american and the
conservatives just don't don't really
offer any moral view anymore even if we
have them we we're too afraid to
articulate it but we have to have a
purpose speaking of not having a purpose
david hogg do you remember david hogg
he's one of the kids who he was at that
school in florida where the shooting one
of the shootings took place
and he
used that as an opportunity to become
somewhat famous and he immediately
jumped on tv and he turned this into a
small sort of celebrity industry for
himself and then he was accepted to
harvard
basically just on the basis of going on
tv a lot after a school shooting
and he's become a sort of poster child
for really simplistic
platitudinous liberal slogans so david
hogg tweeted out something yesterday
that was really sad i'm not mentioning
this to dunk on david hogg i'm on a
mission of mercy to try to help this
poor kid he tweets out quote
i'm never planning on having kids i
would much rather own a porsche and have
a portuguese water dog and golden doodle
long term it's cheaper better for the
environment and will never tell you that
it hates you or asks you to pay for
college
brutal now the immediate conservative
response to this i noticed a lot of
people in the comments section they said
great
thanks bro please don't procreate we
don't need any more david hoggs i don't
think that's charitable and i don't
think it's the right thing to say and i
actually don't think it's even
the right way to think about politics
we are not going to get a more
conservative country by encouraging the
libs to
to
become even more liberal
and self-centered
and
engaging and
disregarding marriage and disregarding
having children disregarding creating
community structures that's actually not
going to work because yes maybe this guy
won't have kids
but
he's going to
it's going to shape the way that the
political community views itself and
over time it's going to make the country
more liberal even if he doesn't have
kids
we're actually not going to out breed
them i don't think okay but furthermore
this is really this is sad
because it's not even that he's saying
i'm not going to have kids and i've got
some higher purpose he's not saying that
i don't think the kids are for everybody
i don't think that marriage is for
everybody
but you do need a higher purpose
you sh you really should not live for
brunch living for brunch is a dead end
it's going to make you completely
miserable and so many of my millennial
and zoomer friends are doing it and they
are miserable as a result of it i can
see it with my own two eyes what's he
say he doesn't say i don't want to have
kids because i want to
join the clergy you know i want to
become a missionary i want no he's
saying
i want to have a nice car
and some fun little want to have some
fun little dogs
and i i fear
that if i have a child i will love that
child and that child will let me down so
i feel suffering at the hands of people
i love so i'm not going to engage in
love in the first place and i fear
losing my money because i don't want to
have to pay for college
bro i get it i get it
i know that it that i understand that
point of view
and especially if you're an atheist and
you don't think there's any real meaning
to life and you think we're all just
kind of sacks of meat stumbling around
until we die and turn to to worm food
and take a dirt nap that you could think
that the purpose of life is just to
give yourself as much
pleasure
in a really shallow understanding of
pleasure as you can but that's not that
ain't it man c.s lewis talks about this
he says
on the subject of shallow pleasure
versus versus deeper pleasure he says
for a little child the little child
cannot imagine anything
more wonderful and enjoyable than
chocolate
and if you mentioned sex to a child
which the libs i guess are doing these
days but if you were to mention sex to a
child the child wouldn't get it you say
actually sex is more more enjoyable and
pleasurable than chocolate
the child the child couldn't fathom that
because the child's frame of reference
is only that chocolate is the greatest
thing ever the child might actually
think huh
well i wonder if sex involves eating
chocolate bars
because it's the only but actually there
are things that are higher and although
now modern libs seem to think that
sexual pleasure with random people is
the highest possible
form of pleasure it's not
there are much higher pleasures
like family which involves you actually
reducing the amount of sex that you can
have with random people you're actually
probably increasing the total amount of
sex you're having because you you have a
wife who likes you and will probably
feel some kind of nagging obligation to
indulge you every now and again so you
can
it will it will limit you in some ways
but it will open you up yes it's true i
love sleeping i don't get to sleep very
much now
i love going out with my friends and
having cigars and drinks i don't get to
do that nearly as much as i once did why
not because i i have to stay home and
see my
children but it's not that i get to stay
home and see my children the joy while
my child is having a complete meltdown
and he's throwing gooey disgusting
food all over the place and there's a
mess everywhere he's screaming and the
other baby starts crying and the the
anxiety that that induces and then i
just look over at my little kid and i
see his cute little chubby little cheeks
it's a little 19 month old baby cheeks
and he does a little kind of like a
little smile at daddy it is a joy that
it is so sublime it's so
unfathomable when you're a kind of glib
lib just living for your own pleasure
that i know i can't actually articulate
how great it is
but i promise i promise you david hogg i
promise you
shallow glib libs there are higher
things here there are higher things
beyond your own basest desires and
appetites and
and
supposed self-interest but actually your
things that you were pursuing today as
your self-interest really will not make
you happy in the long run
it's not making people happy now there's
a study that just came out of harvard
surprising to everyone in the liberal
establishment not surprising at all to
normal people
young people are miserable they are
totally freaking miserable
okay and harvard can't make sense of it
why are young people so miserable quote
according to every dimension of
well-being that we looked at happiness
health meaning character relationships
financial stability those who are 18 to
25 felt they were worse off
this according to tyler vander weil who
conducted the study
they're worse off according to it would
it would make sense that young people
are
have lower reports of happiness
according to
certain metrics maybe then certain
financial stability maybe although i
guess young people
depending on the family structure young
people might feel especially financially
stable because they're still relying on
their parents for certain things but but
yes certain criteria you could maybe
expect them to be a little less happy
maybe than others
but everything
social relationships that when you're
young that's supposed to be when you're
most connected when you're seeing so
many people it's only when you get old
that you kind of stop making time to see
your friends and you become more
isolated your friends die why are young
people miserable on every
metric
we've been told that all of the
progressive advances in society are
supposed to make us all happier
but they have
you could point to pretty much anything
that has changed
in the last 30 50 years
and you could say that is playing a role
in it
technology isolating us from real life
we're told that when we get to live in
the metaverse that's so wonderful and
cool and hip and no it's not we we're
human beings we need to see one another
we need to touch one another
that's why during kovid when people were
hugging through cellophane wrappers that
was so inhuman
we need to in zooming everywhere we need
to see one another we're incarnate
creatures we have bodies
family life we're told it's super cool
now abandon your family don't get
married don't have kids you're gonna be
so happy because you'll get to go to
brunch in whatever city you're in this
weekend
doesn't make people happy and then of
course
the
core of it is religion as religion has
declined people have become miserable
and it is a direct one-to-one
ratio you might be an atheist you might
be an agnostic you i'm just you might
not even get it but i think you know i'm
right
i think you know there's this weird
connection between the two okay
speaking of
following one's bliss
there's a story you know i'm going to
get to this tomorrow i'm just going to
tease it right now i'm going to get to
the story tomorrow though this is very
politically incorrect john boyega
who is he's the actor from star wars the
new star wars movies i think i'm sure
he's been in other stuff he just told gq
magazine
that he only dates black
women he said i only actually don't know
if he's gay or straight these days it's
very confusing but whatever his views he
says
they're his preferences rather he says i
only date black
then it's about chemistry personality
goals is there synergy can i help you
can you help me
not exactly a great way to think about
love affairs but okay i'm very
disciplined to the type of women i speak
to
um
and then he got in big trouble because
he says he only dates black people they
say this is some are saying this is
racist some are saying it's not racist
because black people can't be racist we
will get to what i think about john
boyega
we'll get to what i think about only
dating black ladies
tomorrow for now though we've got to get
to the member block you know some people
get upset about the things that i say
they're completely common sense and
reasonable um and then they get really
upset and start pulling their hair out
there's one such young man he is a tick
talker he's got hundreds of thousands of
followers on tick tock
and i don't i don't go on tiktok but one
of my producers told me he just posted a
video where he's very very angry with me
and he's debunking all of my horrible
terrible claims with facts and logic
apparently it's because i was
criticizing those cartoon lesbian pigs
for the children's show so anyway we'll
get to that in a second the rest of this
show is continuing now you don't want to
miss it if you're not a member click the
link in the description and join us we
will see you at the member block
[Music]
[Music]
you